[Music]
the honest answer is the Sims it was the
greatest my favorite video game was
definitely Tony Hawk skateboarding game
in the video game I could like hear my
bones cracking and stuff and that was
really fun so when I was a kid my
favorite game of all time was harvest
moon 64 which is just a game about
farming it was just very gentle and I
liked my favorite game when I was a kid
was Legend of Zelda and that's what
really kind of got me interested in into
gaming but in my adult life I'd say my
favorite game is probably Skyrim the
first video game believe it or not is
pac-man I know it's a long long time ago
but I'm a long time anyway it's pac-man
my favorite game growing up wasn't
spoken because I have two little
brothers and so I kicked the boy but my
favorite video game growing up would be
contra because that was the first one
that I remember you you had the cheat
code up up down down left right left
right BA
that no contract Zelda was the first
game that opened my mind to a universe
that I just wanted to be in I just
wanted to be in Hyrule
[Music]